the written house trial continues as the
prosecution flails the media largely
overlooked the unfolding ahmed arbury
case and dave portnoy fights back
against a smear attack i'm ben speer
this is the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
ben before we get to all the news let me
just remind you it is very important
that you have life insurance if you're a
responsible human being i mean one day
you might just be riding the bus you're
just taking the bus to work and suddenly
somebody announces that there is a bomb
strapped to the bus and that if the bus
somehow goes below 50 miles an hour then
the bus is entirely going to blow up and
sure there is some sort of federal agent
on hand who gets onto the bus and is and
and does his best to stop it but while
all this is unfolding you might have
thought yourself man i should have
hedged my bets i should have gotten life
insurance policy genius makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius it could save 1300 or more
per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts and policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor getting started super
easy head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare personalized quotes find your
best price when you're ready to apply
policy genius does all the rest head on
over to policygenius.com apparel get
started right now that's policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice and
quite important to get it right okay so
the kyle written house trial continues
to unfold and frankly the reactions are
sort of more interesting than the trial
at this point because it is perfectly
obvious that kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense that was obvious from the
time the footage came out i waited to
sort of make a final judgment on it
until the prosecution brought forth its
case because sometimes you get
information that you didn't have before
it turns out the prosecution not only
didn't have any information the
prosecution witnesses turned into
defense witnesses but it doesn't matter
people are very invested in this
particular case and when you think about
it it doesn't make a lot of sense
why are people in the media so invested
in this particular case and you
understand why they were invested in the
brett kavanaugh case because there we
were talking about a conservative
justice being added to the supreme court
and shifting the balance of the court
from five four republican appointees to
six three republican appointees you
understand why they were so in
in france with the christine blasey ford
claims even though there is no evidence
to back them
you even understand why the left gets
very involved in trials like george
floyd and derek shelvin even though
there was no accusation of racism at
least the races match up with the
narrative that the left wanted to tell
which the black people are routinely
mistreated by white cops
even though the evidence does not show
that black people are under the knee of
american police throughout the nation
due to race and but you understand why
they were pushing that narrative and you
understood that at least the races of
the people involved matched up the kyle
written house trial makes no sense it
doesn't make any sense on sort of a pure
point of view because
kyle written house is white and all
three of the people he shot were white
and all the people who were burning
things that night were white so that's a
lot of white people right so what you're
talking about is a bunch of people who
are burning down kenosha wisconsin
mainly because
they were supposedly angry about the
shooting of jacob blake who happened to
be a career criminal who was shot while
holding a knife after refusing to put
down the knife after police told him put
down the knife they'd been called to the
scene by his ex-wife who was accusing
him of attempting to rape her
in the past and then showing up and
trying to
get the kids in here now so it's a bad
case if you're gonna pick an example of
a controversy that that really
demonstrates how bad america is this is
a bad one
right it's hard to shoehorn it into the
racial narrative and what's really
fascinating is the difference in
attention that's being paid to for
example the arbory trial this trial
versus the arbitrary trial the written
house trial versus the arbor trial the
arbor trial matches up much more closely
with the sort of narrative that the left
wishes to purvey right in that
particular case you have a black man who
gets shot to death after he is on an
open construction site and then runs
away from the open construction site and
some white guys chase him down in the
truck they try to run him off the road
and then finally they blockade the road
and when he tries to they're holding
guns to try and stop him from running
away even though he wasn't effectively
committing a crime there's no accusation
that arberry had committed a crime by
walking around the open construction
site
and uh and he tried to push his way
through
at one point there's a struggle for the
gun and somebody shoots him right that
one seems to match up much more closely
with the narrative that the left would
like to push about how all american
white people are attempting to gun down
all black people are racially profiling
them etc but the disparate amount of
attention paid to the our bury trial
versus the amounts of attention paid to
the written house trial is really
fascinating because again one seems to
fit the narrative and one really does
not so much
so why why you have to ask yourself why
is it that the media are so
really just right on when it comes to
the written house trial just spotlight
laser focus on the written house trial
when it comes to the artery case
well we'll sort of cover it kind of a
little bit and the answer is i think
that for the left once there is a
narrative that they have established
with regard to a particular case like
the written house trial
and once that narrative starts to
implode
you must be lied to you it's not about
trying to convince you that america is
racist or terrible it's that you must be
told
not to believe your eyes as the case
gets worse for the left the left becomes
more ardent about defending the case
so remember the original case the left
wanted to make with regard to written
house the written house was a white
supremacist and the reason that he went
there that night is because he was a
racist who opposed a black lives matter
and the fact that all the people he shot
were white was sort of
irrelevant to the question because those
people were protesting alongside black
lives matter so the big narrative was
rittenhouse giant white supremacist
probably a trump supporter really bad
white guy
and this bad white guy is juxtaposed to
the
coalition of the oppressed
and their white allies
and and so written house is bad and the
people that he shot are good now as the
facts emerged and it turns out that all
three of the people that written how
shot attacked him and that all three had
criminal records and that one was a
child molester and then one of them was
literally raising a gun to shoot kyle
rittenhouse when he was shot
and then the third was bashing hal
rittenhouse in the head with a
skateboard when he was shot
right as that as those facts emerged
you'd imagine that the media might back
off no that's the whole point the media
cannot back off the media must double
down because you must show your faith in
the narrative
the reason that the fact pattern does
not match
for the left that's almost a feature not
a bug
what i mean by that is that when the
fact pattern matches their narrative
everybody agrees that the case should go
one particular way and there's no
disagreement when there is disagreement
the left jumps all over it because they
want to force you to not believe your
own eyes
you see this all the time
and so the left will continue to
maintain that michael brown who was shot
justifiably by a police officer is in
fact a victim of white law enforcement
like today it will claim the michael
brown who by all of the evidence witness
evidence forensic evidence
michael brown attacked a police officer
in a police car and then he tried to run
away and then when the police officer
told him to stop he charged the police
officer and was shot for his trouble
it didn't matter that hands up don't
shoot never happened it became a core
part of the left's narrative in fact if
you didn't believe the narrative this
meant you were bad
right if
there were riots in ferguson missouri
over the shooting of a guy who was
attacking a police officer the president
of the united states barack obama would
get on national tv and say that people
don't make up stories like this even
though this story was literally made up
beginning to end by the media and by
witnesses who were lying about it at the
time
including people who were friends with
michael brown right the michael brown
case was a big focus of the media you
know it wasn't a big focus the media the
walter scott case remember that walter
scott was a black man who was shot in
the back running away from police
officers in south carolina and the
police officer shot him killed him and
then proceeded to plant a gun on him
that officer ended up going to jail
and he ended up being convicted that
doesn't fit the left-wing narrative
which is the entire system is bad so
they have to pick controversial cases
they have to pick a case in which you
or i or anyone else looks at the
evidence and says no i don't think this
fits the narrative because everything
must fit the narrative even if it
doesn't fit the narrative it has to fit
the narrative and if you argue with the
narrative this is just demonstration of
the white supremacy of the system that's
why the left is paying attention to the
written house trial but not paying
attention to the outbreak trial because
there's every possibility in the arbory
trial that based on the available back
pattern that this is going to go down as
manslaughter murder
it's it's pretty incredible it's the
same thing with derek shoving by the way
the derrick shroven george floyd trial
the evidence tended to show i maintain
the evidence tended to show that george
floyd died of essentially
a drug overdose based on his
pre-existing medical conditions and that
he was not in fact killed by the need of
the neck
okay that
that's what the i still believe that
derek shovin should not have been
convicted certainly of murder and
probably not of manslaughter
okay but but the left has to mean
because i maintain that the left has to
maintain that that is evidence that
america is broadly racist they look for
controversial cases they don't want
clear-cut cases clear-cut cases are the
enemy of the left and so they will
continue to maintain in the written
house case the written house is guilty
and that if you oppose the notion the
written house is guilty that you that's
what they're looking for they're looking
for the controversy because these cases
are not about the people at the center
of the cases
these cases are about you and your
reaction these cases about how you react
to the evidence if you react by saying
wait i disagree with the narrative
that's because you are a racist
and even if you're right you're still a
racist and we'll get to more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
your sleep quality so helix sleep makes
a mattress that mattress is basically
the only reason i'm alive today because
i don't get enough sleep when i lie down
on the mattress i need to be out like a
light helix sleep makes it happen for me
because they have a quiz it takes just
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes directly to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
they've got a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights at
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
because helix has financing options and
flexible payment plans a great night's
sleep is never far away i took that
helix quiz and i was matched to a
mattress that is firm because i like to
sleep on a firm mattress and that is
breathable because i tend to heat up at
night let me just tell you it is super
comfortable because it was made just for
me just go to
helixsleep.com take that two minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com
that's helixleep.com
ben alrighty so let me show you case in
point as too as to the left perspective
on the written house trial
so there is a piece today at
nbcnews.com by isaac bailey professor of
public policy at davidson college and
author of why didn't we riot a black man
in trump land yeah i think you know
where this is going and the piece is
called a sobbing kyle written house
already won even before his trial is
over
if convicted he'll become a right-wing
martyr if he is freed it's a message to
others like him that prison won't be in
their future and here is what this
columnist says kyle written house in an
unusual move for a defendant took the
witness stand wednesday he cried his
defense team then made a motion for a
mistrial with prejudice which means
written house couldn't be retried but
whatever the court rules he has already
won
he's charged with reckless homicide
intentional homicide attempted
intentional homicide for shooting three
people killing two of them who are
protesting the police shooting of yet
another black man jacob blake in kenosha
wisconsin last summer
the protest followed many george floyd
inspired ones that erupted across the
world calling for police accountability
and justice for black lives white allies
like the ones written how shot were
among the protester
house has pled not guilty okay so that's
the narrative the narrative is jacob
blake was shot by evil white cops okay
false he was shot because he is a
criminal
who refused to end the threat to the
officers by putting down the knife that
was in his hand
and that's why number one two the
protest that erupted was calling for
police accountability and justice for
black lives really was burning down
local businesses really important to
that particular
thing was that was that the goal the
burning down of the of local businesses
because that's why written house was
there it was because of the burning down
in local businesses i noticed he didn't
show up at just any old protest in
madison wisconsin he showed up in
kenosha where people were literally
burning car lots
and these are white allies right
according to this columnist so if
they're white allies then they are black
adjacent you have to understand that
according to the left the way this works
is that if you are a successful black
person in the united states and don't
buy into the left line and if you're
financially successful
and you don't buy into the left line
about the evils of america this means
that you are white adjacent
right so winsome sears is is white
adjacent over in virginia or clarence
thomas is white adjacent meanwhile if
you are an upper-class tony white
liberal who goes out and throws
firebombs and cop cars you are now
apparently black adjacent or at least a
white ally
according to the left so according to
this piece on nbc news if rittenhouse is
convicted you will likely stop being a
right-wing mascot and become a
right-wing martyr if he isn't convicted
he will set a precedent for others to
like him to pick up guns they shouldn't
have and thrust themselves into the
middle of unrest they should avoid
confident in knowing that prison won't
be in their future i love that at no
point does anybody discuss the fact that
um
gage gross groups had a gun that
presumably he shouldn't have had
and that people were attempting to beat
coward and house to death and that one
of the people who shot was grabbing for
rittenhouse's gun and also happened to
be a child molester like at no point
does any of this match the narrative but
again the narrative is all that matters
to his supporters and many of his
detractors ridden house isn't a monster
not really he was a young dumb kid hyped
up on the foxification or fox news
effect of american discourses on black
lives matter in a country that
fetishizes guns for show for sport for
killing not a white supremacist like say
well not a white supremacist like say
dylan roof not really he wore no hoods
didn't wrap himself in the confederate
flag
he's a patriot who tried to bring calm
to chaos because as fox news primetime
host tucker carlson told us at the time
of the shooting the adults around him
wouldn't maintain order he was so
nonviolent police officers greeted him
and those like him fellow guardians of
the community before he killed anyone
he didn't open fire until absolutely
necessary it was self-defense his
supporters have told us outside the
courtroom and his lawyers have argued
inside the courtroom had criminals not
rushed him had they not provoked him
they would be alive he would not have
been charged he defended himself that's
all
i mean look at his red tear stained face
on the stand so compelling the judge
stopped the trial for 10 minutes to
allow rittenhouse to compose himself his
tears tell the story
said he was trying to do good to protect
this dying nation and that's the same
nonsense claim people have been using
throughout the u.s right here's where
this columnist gets to the point the
idea is that if you defend anyone from
chaos and disorder if you defend the
system in any way if you act in
self-defense this means that you are
evil and you're evil on the order of
people who stormed the capital your evil
on the order of people who want to end
critical race theory like it's all into
one big this is what they do they spin
every little incident into it's a giant
ball of narrative and predominantly
white voters were trying to defend their
freedom so they flock to an open bigot
like donald trump and storm the us
capital angry parents most of them white
are storming school board meetings
demanding an end to critical race theory
lessons to protect white children from
feeling guilt politicians and local
officials have stoked this by framing
the teaching of race and books that
explore its context as something
constituents should defend their
communities from
the truth is that too many white
americans probably see themselves in
written house afraid of anyone whether
white or of color wants to live in a
more equitable country even if some
don't want to say so out loud so this is
the narrative the narrative is the kyle
written house is a stand-in for all of
white america who's deeply afraid of the
intersectional coalition and defending
white america against their predations
so many things have pointed to they're
being scared as rittenhouse was
described to have been during the
protest and in the aftermath of the
shooting frightened of losing the
country their hard-working salt of the
earth parents and grandparents built of
becoming a minority among minorities of
being displaced as the de facto right
way to be a real patriotic american of
being able just to define what that
means but it wasn't just fear that
convinced rittenhouse that he had a
right a responsibility even to take a
gun into the middle of unrest that
didn't directly affect him it was an
entitlement as well by the way i love
how the moral impetus has shift here
shifted here right the responsibility
here doesn't lie with people not to burn
down cities it allows you not to go and
try and stop people from burning down
cities
really solid stuff but again this is the
so this is why the left is so invested
in this because they have basically
wrapped this up into a broad-scale
narrative that kyle rittenhouse as
always is a microcosm of white america
generally and because he wished to
defend private property
from people who are burning it down this
means that he was standing against the
march of progress in the united states
this is why regardless of the verdict
says this columnist for nbc news it's up
to the rest of us to guarantee different
outcomes we need to make sure the
disparity in who has afforded life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness is
honestly and continually discussed and
see to it that those tenets of american
democracy are extended to those who have
historically been left out if you care
about saving this democracy from the
kyle written houses of the world you
shouldn't look to a judge and jury
kyle written houses a threat to
democracy you see even if he acted in
self-defense it was a threat to
democracy in fact because he acted in
democracy because any white person who
acts in self-defense is actually just a
reactionary attempting to defend from
that march of progress this is the
left-wing narrative and this is why the
left is so invested in this case
deeply invested in this case
and they'll come up with any excuse why
written house should not be acquitted
because they're so invested in the case
and explicitly because written house
should not be convicted written house
should be convicted because society
demands that written house be convicted
the circumstances of the case cutting in
favor of written house that's actually
just a religious demand on you right you
should have faith in the woke narrative
regardless of the facts you have to take
that leap of faith and embrace it
the more you the more you look at the
evidence and the more you think maybe
written how should get off the more you
are betraying you are a heretic you are
betraying the narrative
we'll get to more of this in just one
moment first if you're looking for ways
to skip the trip to the post office and
dodge all the hectic holiday shopping
traffic there's an easy way to do that
you could be saving time and saving
money with stamps.com the lines are
getting longer everywhere going to the
post office is sort of a fool's errand
at this point you want to stand in line
for an hour just to get to the front of
the line and send packages that you
could be sending at a discount with
stamps.com
here at dailywire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017 we do not waste
our time whether you're selling online
or running an office or side hustle
stamps.com can save you so much time and
money and stress during the holidays
access you post office and ups shipping
services you need without taking the
trip
and you can get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to 40 off usps
rates and 76 off ups going to the post
office instead of using stamps.com it's
kind of like taking the stairs instead
of the elevator
if you're going up just a couple of
floors you need to send one letter oh
just drop in the mailbox or something
but if you are sending a lot of packages
you owe it to yourself to
gogetstamps.com
save time and money this holiday season
with stamps.com sign up with promo coach
shapiro for a special offer that
includes a four week trial free postage
digital scale no long term commitments
no contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
enter code shapiro to get started today
okay so the media are going to just keep
giving witnesses who testified to
written house's self-defense a second
bite at the apple because the narrative
must be preserved so best example of
this gage gross croods
who has a criminal record and who is in
fact a member of a radical left-wing
quasi-militant organization that's why
he was in kenosha wisconsin he was the
guy who was approaching powell
rittenhouse with a pistol in his hand by
video evidence and then he lied to the
police and he told the police that his
gun was on the floor not because he had
taken it out to point it at kylo right
house and presumably shoot him he had
taken out the gun
by accident it had fallen out of his
pocket or out of his holster or whatever
it was and then the video showed that
wasn't true
so on the stand he admitted that britain
house did not shoot him until he removed
the gun from his holster and started to
approach kyle rittenhouse well now he's
on good morning america
now he's on good morning america talking
about his view of kyle rittenhouse
and what was your reaction to to him
breaking down and crying on the stand
timid seemed like a
a child who had
just gotten
caught doing something that he wasn't
supposed to more upset that he was
caught and
less upset about
what he had done and
what he had taken
and
the numerous lives that he affected
through you literally testified in open
court that he did not shoot you until
you tried to take a gun out and shoot
him and now you're being given time on
good morning america to revise your
statement and say that that really this
is about how hal rittenhouse is guilty
and went to kill that night
right the the narrative must be
maintained at all costs you have joy
behar saying that kyle rittenhouse
crying was some of the worst acting i've
ever seen
well i mean she has an imdb and let me
just say joy behar is no great shakes
here she was
from what i'm gleaning from this case
the guy goes across state lines with an
ar-15 with his mother and some other
idiot in the car
to defend himself against what they're
having a protest in another state and he
takes it upon himself to go there you
know and then he says it's self-defense
no
and that that acting job of the crying i
can't even look at it well this is
that is one of the worst acting dogs
i've ever seen
and then she gets they start to applaud
and then she uh it gets in in her small
p brain that uh that this is a popular
point of view and so she just repeats it
well look at that acting job just it
this is the takeaway the takeaway is
that kyle written house is evil and if
you don't believe that kyle rittenhouse
is evil if you believe that even if you
believe it was a mistake for him to go
here because he's a 17 year old kid and
he probably shouldn't have been there at
the time
and you believe that that the police
should have been there doing the job
instead even you believe all that that
does not mean that he didn't act in
self-defense he just dismisses the
self-defense because again the idea is
that if you went across state lines to
defend private property this is the evil
act understand that she thinks that
people should be prosecuted for going
and defending private property that's
really at the root of this if you stand
up in any way to the black lives matter
riots that happened last year you are
bad period even if you didn't shoot
anybody and so whatever happens
afterward really is on you
now listen the prosecution continues to
collapse in on itself like a dying star
it's really impressive so yesterday for
example the prosecutor tried to
establish the bias if they witnessed
drew hernandez who shot the footage i
don't know how this would in any way
discredit the footage right the footage
that that was available
is footage that is available it is on
tape that's the beautiful thing about
footage but here's the prosecutor trying
to discredit the witness by suggesting
that the witness has a personal bias
the answer to this would be normally so
the hell what
your
videos that you have captured of these
incidents that you call riots
they're
very
slanted against the people who are
rioting you characterize them as antifa
black lives matter rioters correct
because they are rioting in the footage
yes absolutely do you as you sit here
today do you personally know the
defendant no
but yet you call him by his first name
that's his legal name what else am i
supposed to call him
uh so um ignore the footage again so
much of this is ignore what your own
eyes tell you and just pay attention to
what i'm telling you
okay so all of this is going sideways
really fast on the people who are trying
to preserve the narrative because the
facts don't match up
so as i said yesterday the media have
already turned this into the judge is
bad it's the judge's fault it's not our
fault for lying to you and they did they
lied to you for a year hey this happened
last year they've been lying to you for
a year about what exactly happened in
kenosha wisconsin it's been available on
tape they've been fibbing about it
in some cases not even fibbing calling
him a domestic terrorist and a white
supremacist and a person who went there
to kill that night and all of that's
falling apart on them so now it's the
judge is bad
who by the way the judge is normally
predisposed to defendants apparently
according to people who practiced in
front of him now normally that's
something that i thought democrats were
in favor of right the rights of the
accused were a thing that democrats were
big in favor of if you if you had to
sort of break down politics normally
people who are pro-prosecution people
who are pro-defense typically it sort of
lines up right left right if you're if
you're a right-wing you tend to be more
pro-prosecution generally and if you're
left-wing you tend to be more
pro-defense generally okay well you're
supposed to follow the facts of the case
in any case but the normal
predisposition is that way okay so when
it comes to a judge right it's usually
been conservatives we're like yeah we
want the hanging judge and then you've
got liberals who are like no we want the
judge who's going to pat everybody on
the back and tell them to go get a
social worker right so this is the
social worker judge this is the judge
who's like we would like for you to make
sure that all the defendants are
treated well and and now the left is
like this guy's a jerk this guy's the
worst so they had some outside
indicators that he was the worst what
are the outside indicators that he is
the worst so he made a joke about the
supply chain crisis before break
yesterday
he made a joke about how
he was having asian food and he hoped
that the the food had not been held up
at the port of long beach
but he said the word asian
which means that he's a racist
which would impact this case because
there are so many asians involved
or some thing here was the judge saying
a super not racist thing and uh and then
being accused of being a racist
let's hope for one o'clock i don't know
the uh hope the asian food isn't coming
it's not isn't on one of those boats in
long long beach harbor
i i don't understand how it's even
remotely supposed to be racist i'm sorry
i just don't
there there's asian food
or is he saying that the food that is
from asia might be held up in long beach
because he's making a joke about the the
shipping supply crisis
it seems like not an anti-asian joke it
seems more like eating the asian it
seems like he's
mainly criticizing the port of long
beach in that joke
the entire media goes oh my god he's a
racist he's a racist he's a brutal
terrible racist i mean how dare he um i
noticed that yesterday joe biden called
someone a negro
like that's an actual thing that joe
biden did yesterday
no he did it by accident but i can just
promise you that if a republican or if
this judge had used the kind of language
that joe biden used yesterday then the
media would be going insane
i have a question what's worse just on
sort of a pure level just a pure kind of
like root racist level a judge saying i
hope that that
asian food gets delivered today because
there's a shipping crisis in la or the
president of the united states
describing satchel paige as a negro by
accident
which is worse here's joe biden doing
that yesterday
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson his name was satchel page okay
so
what what's funny listen i'll give joe
biden the benefit of the doubt there i
mean i don't even think you have to
benefit that i think pretty clearly joe
biden just loses his train of thought
and what he meant to say is that great
pitcher in the negro leagues
right by the way by federal law you're
not allowed to use the word negro in
legislation for example so that's that's
not a great look there for joe biden but
these guys are approximately the same
age right joe biden is 78 years old
the judge in this particular case
bruce schrader uh i believe that he is
he's i know he's up there as well he's
been practicing for like 50 years and
he's 75 and he's about the same age as
joe biden but the idea is that he is a
racist and joe biden is not a racist and
the answer is because joe biden is a
leftist and this judge is not
giving the left what it wants in this
particular case then then something even
worse happened to the judge
demonstrating that he's a super duper
giant racist who's horrible and racist
during the middle of the trial his cell
phone rang his ringtone
that racist anthem directly from the
slave holding south god bless the usa by
lee greenwood
if the court makes a finding that
the actions that i had talked about
[Music]
we're done in bad faith
okay and the media were like oh my god
oh my god he's got god bless the usa on
his phone that probably means he's
please guys keep going down this path
seriously i would love for you to keep
going down the path where if anybody
likes god bless the usa this means they
shouldn't be a judge and they're racist
really just just go full anti-american
seriously god bless the usa wow how dare
he how dare he
but this is exactly where you get eli
mistah over on msnbc saying clearly this
is a racist biased judge
we have as a judge who from my
perspective has prejudged the trial in
favor of written house and has decided
again even at the pre-trial stage to use
every bit of his power to put his thumb
on the scale towards written house's
side that's what schroeder is he is he
has made a series of decisions each one
perhaps may be individually defensible
but in totality
lead to the impression of a biased
racist judge with his trump rally cell
phone um uh that is trying to get rid of
the house uh a walk okay my favorite
thing there is where he says that each
one of the decisions the judge is making
is defensible but in totality he's a
giant racist who loves trump
interesting take interesting take then
you get maya wiley the rejected
candidate for mayor of new york who says
yeah yeah the rittenhouse trial judge he
seems predisposed to the defense
oh is that what's happening here or is
it possible that maybe the defense just
has a better case
this judge you know from the outside
looking in and i haven't been inside
that courtroom but certainly seems to be
predisposed in some ways to the defense
um and his level of anger and response
and some instances allowing the defense
to use work like mobs and rioters
when the prosecution cannot use words
like victims you know for the people who
are killed and harmed in this case those
are the kinds of things it's not a
balanced approach okay i have a question
it's not a
right
it's not a balanced approach you can't
call them victims because the entire
case is about whether they are victims
the question is to whether it was
self-defense or not it's not about
whether they were rioters
it could be it could be not self-defense
if they were writers right if you'd just
gone out there with his ar and he just
started shooting rioters in the street
wouldn't matter if they're rioters or
not it could be both rioters and victims
these are not mutually exclusive
but apparently if you
in order to be not racist or something
you have to say that these rioters were
not rioters and also you have to say
that they were victims that is the
definition of prejudging the case and
finally we have bree newsome bass who is
a uh an anti-racism activist bree newsom
uh and she of course says that the judge
is predisposed toward not just the
defense toward white supremacy
so we know that i mean even apart from
the long history of collaboration
between police forces white supremacist
organizations and white militias we have
a very recent history of this as well
we've had situations where police kill
someone there is protesting and then in
addition to
the police presence in the street which
is a problem uh we have white militia
groups showing up white supremacist
organizations showing up the history of
judges who are sympathetic to white
supremacists has a very long history as
well oh so the judge is white
supremacist now my favorite part of that
is which just sort of slips in that the
cops being in the community is bad so we
can't have cops defending the community
and you can't have citizens defending
the community so um everybody's just
supposed to burn it down so again the
narrative here is believe us not your
lying eyes and if you refuse to do that
this means that you are in league with
white supremacy meanwhile as we'll get
to in a second the media have been
largely overlooking what's going on in
the arbory case which again is a much
better example of at least a case where
there are dueling perspectives on what
happened and that should theoretically
fit their narrative better if the case
comes down in favor of the guilds of the
people who shot arbory we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about a simple fact and that is gas is
way too expensive right now which is why
you need get upside get upside is the
free app that allows you to save money
every time you fill your tank at the
pump my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code shapiro
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back don't pay full price of the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free use promo
code shapiro to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred bucks a
month in cash back there's no cash the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out any times your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your very first
tank of gas that is promo code shapiro
go get that get upside app right now
it's a free app at the app store and use
promo code to appear to get 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank 25
cents back every gallon of gas after
that get upside go check it out right
now okay so now onto the arbor case so
the amount of attention being paid to
the murder of ahmed arberi or the
alleged murder of ahmed arberi is um
wildly disproportionate to the amount of
attention that's being paid to the
written house trial which is quite
fascinating now i've as i always do
withheld judgments on this case until i
see the full evidence so here's what we
know about the the arbory case and it
really shouldn't be called the the
arbory case it really
typically because the written house
trial is is named after the person who's
being tried or the chalvin trial is
being named after the defendant
uh derek chovin the the
in this case the the real issue the the
trial really should be named
after the people who are being
prosecuted in this particular case but
here is what the new york times says the
graphic footage of the killing of bob
madbury is not the only crucial video
evidence in the trial of the three men
accused of murdering him on thursday a
jury in brunswick georgia was shown
surveillance camera footage that depicts
arbory a 25 year old black man making
several visits to the same partially
constructed home at 220 satia drive in
the months before he died in each
instance mr arbury an avid jogger is in
shorts he looks around the house and
leaves the last video recorded in the
early afternoon of february 23 2020
shows arbory visiting the home minutes
before he was chased by the three white
defendants who have said they suspected
him of a series of break-ins in the
neighborhood that chase ended with
arbory being fatally shot by one of the
men in the middle of a nearly suburban
street nearby suburban street
jurors on thursday were also shown a
videotaped deposition of the home's
owner larry english he describes his
concerns about the man who kept showing
up in the house he was building and the
items he suspected had been stolen from
him he described his calls to the police
alerting them to the man's presence he
said he had texted his concerns about
the man as well as two other trespassers
to a neighbor in the satish shores
subdivision which defense lawyers said
was on the edge over a wave of property
crime the videos and mr english's
response to them are likely to be
central to the case
of whether the defendants had a legal
right to chase arboret so what happened
in this particular case is that
the people in the nearby area got a call
that arbury was hanging out at this
house again it was a construction site
and apparently some stuff had been
stolen from the house
in the past and he took off running down
the street they chased him in the car as
i mentioned they were in a couple of
trucks they tried to run him off the
road then they tried to roadblock him he
tried to run around the roadblock one of
the people was holding a shotgun and uh
actually a couple of people were holding
guns and he went for the gun of one of
the guys who was blocking the road and
in the struggle over the gun
that guy shot him okay so the question
is whether that is self-defense or not
and that really relies not on the action
in the moment it relies on whether they
were justified in trying to arrest him
in the first place if they were trying
to arrest him or whether they were
justified in road blocking him in the
first place he said that that is a
secondary legal issue
okay the the the primary legal issue
here is whether they were justified
because once once there's a struggle
over the gun and then somebody shoots
somebody else
a self-defense claim comes into play the
question is whether you were allowed to
be out there
in the first place in this particular
case and when i say out there i mean
like actually trying to stop somebody
from running away
mr english a general contractor who
lives in douglas georgia about 90
minutes from brunswick suffers from
serious health issues he did not give
his testimony in person during his
deposition english described the
numerous times that video of arbor
appeared on security cameras around the
property the footage was sent to his
cell phone in some cases he called the
glenn county police department asking
that an officer go to the house to check
things out although english was
concerned about the theft the videos
never showed aubry taking anything from
the property at one point english was
monitoring the situation from afar
exchanged text messages with a man named
diogo diego perez who lived near the
house english sent perez video footage
of arbory on the property as well as
footage of another man and woman who
were detected at the house one night
notably english says he never shared
directly with the three defendants his
concerns that arbury had been on his
property in fact he barely knew two of
the defendants travis mcmichael the man
who shot arbory or his father gregory
mcmichael whom he said he had met only
briefly he said he had never met the
third defendant william bryan
linda danikowski the lead prosecutor may
use such details to buttress her
argument that the defendants rushed into
action based on flawed assumptions and
driveway decisions but without immediate
knowledge that a crime had occurred
donatkowski's language echoes that
echoes that found in what was georgia's
citizens arrest law at the time which
stated that a private person could
arrest someone if an offense was
committed in their presence or within
their immediate knowledge
in opening statements for the defense
robert rubin a lawyer for travis
mcmichael brought attention to another
aspect of the law which stated that if
someone believed that another person had
committed a felony and if that person
was escaping or trying to escape it was
legal to try to arrest the fleeing
person if the pursuer harbored
reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion rubin contends that english
allowed suspicion to spread in the
neighborhood by sharing the videos of
arbory's unauthorized entries with perez
and the police and by letting it be
known that some property had in fact
been stolen from his boat reuben said of
the defendants were not contending a
crime was committed in their presence
but there was probable cause to believe
a felony had been committed and this man
was attempting to escape or flee
okay so this is the key legal issue at
this time each of the defendants in the
case has been indicted on nine counts
including malice murder which involves
showing that a killing was carried out
with an abandoned and malignant heart
apparently prosecutors were laying the
groundwork for that charge by eliciting
testimony from police officers that
showed some of the harsh language
gregory mcmichael used to describe
arbory shortly after he was killed
including referring to him with a vulgar
insult
niemah rahmani a former federal
prosecutor pointed out that the men were
also charged with felony murder which
applies when a death is caused in the
course of committing another felony
irrespective of malice
also they are claiming that this is
false imprisonment so in other words if
they didn't have probable cause to stop
the guy then they couldn't actually stop
the guy so this is you know a case that
should theoretically
been
should it should be like front page news
right because it does tend to at least
fit the narrative or raise the issues
that the left likes to talk about a lot
a racial profiling there's a difference
in race between the men who shot arbury
and arbory
and this has become a pretty racially
fraught trial right from the get-go al
sharpton showed up with trial benjamin
crump who lies about the situations of a
wide variety of these situations uh
showed up in the courtroom as well and
the defense attorney asked if if
sharpton could be removed from the room
at the very least he said we shouldn't
have uh activists in the room at all but
he used some pretty fired up language
about it that is going to be very
controversial
obviously there's only so many pastors
they can have and in fact their pastors
al sharpton right now that's fine but
then that's it we don't want any more
black pastors coming in here or other
jesse jackson whoever was in was in here
earlier this week sitting with the
victim's family trying to influence a
jury in this case i think the court can
understand
my concern
about bringing people in who really
don't have any ties to this case other
than political interests
okay so this became very controversial
because black pastors the case he's
actually making here is that the the
pastors
who are showing up are not actual family
pastors they're just very very famous
people who are showing up to sit with
the family in order to intimidate the
jury okay so we'll see if the media
starts to catch on to this trial at all
but here's the thing most people are
withholding judgment in the written
house case a lot of people weren't
because the tape was out there and
because the circumstances were fairly
clear from the get-go this one has not
polarized along political lines sort of
like the walter scott case right people
are sort of waiting to see what happens
in the testimonies the left can't use it
the left only likes picking cases where
they are actually fairly often in the
wrong they like those cases because
those cases demonstrate you're fealty
that's what that's about alrighty in
just one second we'll get to dave
portnoy of barstool sports who's
basically being railroaded by business
insider at this point by all available
evidence we'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk about crypto so
i am an owner of crypto i own some
bitcoin i own some ethereum
i i've done really well on both of those
investments the reason that i like
crypto is because crypto is protected by
blockchain the blockchain basically
means that you can't create new crypto
in wild new ways and what i mean by that
is that unlike the american dollar where
you can just pump dollars into the
system you're really not supposed to be
able to do that with crypto which means
it's a good repository of value well
i'm saying that i think you should
consider an alto crypto ira with an alto
crypto ira you can trade crypto like
bitcoin and you can avoid or defer the
taxes and get into investing in crypto
do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account
as crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira
trade all you want without the tax
headache create an account in just a few
minutes invest with as little as 10 no
setup charges secure trading 24 7
through alto's integration with coinbase
there are 80 plus coins available
including bitcoin ethereum and cardano
if you want some sushi swap with your
bitcoin no problem alto has you covered
industry-leading security multiple ways
to fund your account make cash
contribution you can transfer money from
an existing ira you can roll over an old
401k open an alto crypto ira account
with as little as 10 bucks just go to
alto ira dot com slash ben it's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com and go to
auto-ira.com
ben already in just a moment
into more on dave portnoy and some
breaking news from yemen we'll get to
that in a moment first last week as you
know the daily wire filed a lawsuit
against the federal government the biden
administration for the unconstitutional
vacs mandate they're going to try to
cram into place in early january the
fifth circuit court of appeals has
already issued a temporary state but the
fight is just beginning because this is
going to get elevated to the supreme
court i have no doubt about that and joe
biden is determined to cram this down on
you he says you should just ignore the
fifth circuit court of appeals if you're
a business owner and just push his
mandate into place anyway we're not
doing that and we're not doing that just
because we care about our own employees
right we do care about our own employees
and we do not think that it is right
that employers should be forcing their
employees to vaccinate against their own
personal beliefs or in spite of their
own personal scientific data we think
that all americans should be allowed to
make these decisions because this is
still purportedly a free country we need
your help to fight back if you want to
support that fight sign our petition
against joe biden's authoritarian
mandate hundreds of thousands of
americans have already signed the
petition in just a few days we need many
more to stand with us to reach our goal
please head on over to dailywire.com
do not comply to sign the petition today
also in a bit of fun news daily wires
own andrew clavin
you know he's a novelist right his
newest book when christmas comes it's
available everywhere you buy books
dean koontz describes the book as
wonderful gripping a pure delight the
book centers around the story of a
sleuthing english teacher who will need
a christmas miracle to prove a condemned
man innocent it's a seasonal tale of
tradition family and of course murder
it's chilling twists our best experience
curled up beside a burning yule log next
to a corpse go pick up a copy for
yourself or your thrill seeking loved
ones at amazon or anywhere you buy books
today just in time for christmas you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile in news that
apparently no longer matters it's
fascinating how
things that if they had happened under
the trump administration would be front
page news four months they they last for
a little while and then they're gone so
as you know afghanistan is still a thing
that is happening
there are still americans stuck in
afghanistan there's still tens of
thousands of american siv holders
in afghanistan and the place is a
hellhole backwater probably millions of
people will starve to death over the
course of the next couple of years so
things are great there also who the
rebels have now stormed the american
embassy in yemen and taken hostages
according to the washington free beacon
now you've seen this reported pretty
much nowhere because apparently we're
not supposed to care
the the houthi rebels are a gang of
shia militiamen who are backed by the
iranian government they are terrorists
the biden administration because it was
trying to make nice with the iranians
came into office and took them off the
terrorist they now took over the
american embassy in yemen and now
they've taken hostages according to the
state department the majority of the
detained have been released but the
houthis continue to detain additional
yemeni employees of the embassy this is
one of the ways that islamic terror
groups tend to target american allies
they'll say oh well the americans they
can go but if you work with the
americans we're going to shoot you and
we're going to shoot your families if
you think that has no impact on american
interest i don't know what you are
smoking houthi fighters repeatedly
reportedly took the compound on
wednesday demanding large quantities of
equipment and materials for the middle
east media research institute
yemen has been embroiled in a brutal
civil war between the houthi rebels who
are backed by the iranians and the
standing yemeni government which has the
support of saudi arabia
as you remember joe biden removed the
foreign terrorist organization's
designation placed on the houthis by the
trump administration the designation had
cut the houthis off from financial
support
and anthony blink and the secretary of
state called the decision a recognition
of the dire humanitarian situation in
yemen that meant that people could start
supporting the houthis again they
promptly have taken over the american
embassy in yemen so that that apparently
is not worthy of coverage at this point
and because obviously everything biden
does is great
and speaking of foreign policy and
history i just have to make a quick side
point here so nicole hannah jones who
teaches history to your children via the
1619 project which has now been
mainlined into hundreds of institutions
across the united states backed by the
new york times backed by school boards
across the country the 1619 project is a
pack of lies about how every institution
in the united states was founded in sin
and slavery and thus must be torn to the
ground
it's incredible that this woman is
considered some sort of historian when
she doesn't know anything she is just an
idiot i'm sorry she doesn't know things
like basic things so yesterday for
example she had tweeted out
about the dropping of the a-bomb and she
suggested that the dropping of the
a-bomb was deeply wrong and you should
be ashamed of america for the dropping
of the a-bomb okay now that's a fairly
common perspective on the left is that
the dropping of the a-bomb was bad in my
personal opinion the dropping of the
a-bomb was necessary because if it did
not happen the japanese government was
not going to surrender they were going
to make their final stand on the island
of japan proper and that would have
cost the lives of maybe a million
americans it was going to be very very
ugly by internal documentation inside
the japanese imperial regime at the time
they had no intention of actually
surrendering
until the a-bomb was dropped at which
point their calculus changed pretty damn
quickly okay but
even the people who make the argument
that the united states should not have
dropped the a-bomb basically make the
following two arguments one that the
united states wouldn't have had to do
that that japan would have surrendered
anyway and that too the real reason that
the united states dropped the a-bomb was
not because they wanted to get japan to
surrender but because they wanted to
intimidate the soviets because they knew
that the soviets were were very
aggressive and they were pushing very
hard in southeast asia and so in order
to try and
deter the soviets from getting
aggressive at the end of world war ii we
dropped the a-bomb on japan right that
is the revisionist historian take it's
not really supported by the evidence but
that's at least what the take is okay
nicole hannah jones is such an idiot
that she doesn't even know what the take
is so she tweeted out yesterday you're
the one who poorly understands history
they dropped the bomb when the new
surrender was coming because they'd
spent all this money developing it and
to prove it was worth it propaganda is
not history my friend
um okay first of all propaganda is not
history coming from nicole hannah jones
is just the funniest thing in the entire
world because all she does all day is
create propaganda that is not history
but what's even more incredible is that
she is actually making the argument i
can't wait to see the footnotes on this
the argument that the reason the united
states dropped the a-bomb was to prove
that it was money well spent
yes that's right we eviscerated 50 000
people just to prove that we hadn't
wasted money on uh robert oppenheimer
solid take there nicole hannah jones
this woman is teaching your kids history
that's yes that's exactly what that
first of all we know the federal
government is meticulous about ensuring
that you know your dollars are well
spent second of all when we have to
ensure the dollars are well spent we
just bomb people
we just drop nuclear weapons on folks
what an idiot she is i mean truly a
full-scale and the fact that so
many people treat her as an intellectual
is beyond me between her and ibrahmax
candy the man the combined
wattage from that iq pair might be able
to toast a piece of bread lightly like
very lightly like wouldn't be even hot
enough to melt the butter that wow
geniuses
okay so i promised i was gonna get into
this dave portnoy story and so i shall
so first of all
let's begin with this simple fact
we need more people to stand up and
refuse to be canceled in this society
and increasingly we're starting to see
that right so dave chappelle refused to
be counseled by the seven
trans advocates over at netflix
the the cancellation efforts continue by
the way according to politico at the
duke ellington school of arts in
georgetown the students refused dave
chappelle's money
the high school planned a fundraiser
with his famed alum for november 23rd
but quietly cancelled the event due to
an uproar over the remarks that he made
in his netflix special the closer
apparently many of their classmates
identified as lgbtq plus ia to a greater
than sign star little carrot
percentage sign dollar sign hashtag
okay they all identified as that so the
students were uncomfortable supporting
dave chappelle even though he'd given a
bunch of money to the school he gave a
hundred thousand dollars to the school
gave it one of his emmy awards in 2017
delivered a commencement address for the
school but he also says that men exist
and women exist and so that means that
uh his own his old high school is angry
with him and won't take his money
anymore but chappelle is standing up to
that dave portnoy is another person who
is standing up to this now the story
about dave portnoy is that there is a a
outlet called business insider and they
dedicated eight and a half months there
was a reporter named julia black who
dedicated eight and a half months to
tracking down people who had had sex
with dave portnoy and then trying to gin
up an article suggesting that dave
portnoy abuses women against their
consent right that is the gist of the
article the article's headline is quote
i was literally screaming in pain young
women say they met bar stool sports
founder dave portnoy for sex and it
turned violent and humiliating now
nowhere in the article is there an
allegation of rape nowhere in the
article is there an allegation that they
asked portland to stop doing something
and he continued to do it okay so
basically what this story seems to
amount to
is women who are talking to the reporter
by the way said that she was originally
writing the article about dave portnoy's
business strategy because this is what
reporters do they start off talking
business strategy and then they wildly
veer off into the sex lives of the
people that they are covering or
alternatively that's not true and she
was just trying to track down anyone who
had sex with dave portnoy because let's
face it dave portnoy when it comes to
his personal life uh he does not live
his life the way that i would live my
life let's just put it that way on a
moral level i just think that it is a
bad idea to run around banging 19 year
old instagram models i just think that
that is a bad way to live your life but
that's not really the issue here the
issue here is
why exactly the media have determined
that it is bad to go around spending
your life banging 19 year old instagram
models when this is literally what
leonardo dicaprio does and they think
he's great like the way that the left
works is that every single person is who
is of the left can be as sexually
profligated as they want to be in fact
you are rewarded for being sexually
profligate if you're on the left if
you're a if you are a marriage abiding
standards keeping solid family man on
the left you are less worthy of
emulation and celebration by the left
than if you nail everything in sight of
all genders and inanimate objects right
this makes you a hero on the left so if
you're if you're not on the left and you
do this however the standard radically
shifts and the standard shifts just
randomly like the left will just go
after and every so often they'll sort of
pick somebody and just smack him for no
reason just to demonstrate they can
change the rules at any time remember a
few years ago in the middle of me too
there's a big story about aziz ansari
who went on a date with a woman took her
home they had sex twice and then
afterward they were like going at it a
third time and she was like i don't like
this she's like okay bye she left he
didn't call again that was somehow a
story
he went on a special and quasi
apologized for it as though he had done
something deeply wrong now i think that
he had done something wrong because i'm
a traditional moralist but if you're not
a traditional moralist and all you care
about is the value of consent as opposed
to you know the holiness of marriage and
the and the soulful nature of sexual
activity with somebody that you actually
love as opposed to just banging it out
right
like if you're just somebody who doesn't
care about any of that i don't know how
you were angry at aziz i'm sorry
okay but they went after us he's i'm
sorry anyway because every so often the
left has to find somebody to just whap
in the back of the head so they can say
oh well okay well you know
we are in control so if you
you didn't even cross us this time but
as a warning to the others we're just
going to show that we can just punch her
right in the stack and everything
because we rule the roost okay so there
are no standards for the left
which means that dave portnoy is now bad
for engaging in precisely the behavior
that the left celebrates because sex is
basically just a biological function to
the left that should be celebrated
anywhere and everywhere it occurs under
all circumstances it is not a question
of why it is not a question of the
person you are having sex with it is
just a question of who wants to get
their rocks off at what time and did
anybody say no those are the only issues
that that should matter to the left
unless they're busy making an example of
somebody for no reason just to
demonstrate their power okay so business
insider runs this story and here's the
story quote in the summer of 2020
madison sent barstool sports founder
dave portnoy a direct message on
instagram complimenting his famous one
bite pizza reviews sick pizza reviews
she wrote thanks fly portnoy
responded she was a 20 year old college
student at the time portnoy a 43 year
old multi-millionaire the conversation
soon moved to snapchat and text where
quickly turned to the topic of sex well
there's a shock he sent her graphic
videos of other women he'd slept with
according to madison and in messages
reviewed by insider he pressed her to
tell him about her sexual fantasies
and she wrote i mean actually this one's
kind of common like a rape fantasy where
i don't have any control of what's going
on
you and i are going to get along so well
he responded but i will say in order to
do that one i have to be pretty
comfortable with you madison said of
course portnoy said and he bought her a
first-class plane ticket to visit him at
his 2.2 million dollar nantucket home
the trip was a traumatic experience
madison told insider she arrived at four
at portnoy's four-bedroom home about 3
pm okay so let me just start here stop
here
here's the standard
you can consent consent consent when you
say no the note is good however if we
are trying to establish evidence that
dave portnoy did something bad to you
that you did not want to do i can tell
you how you obscure our ability to
believe your story
you have sexual you have sexual text
messages claiming that you want to be
raped or that you have a rape fantasy
you then
accept a ticket from a man 23 years your
senior who's explicitly sent you
messages of other women he's had sex
with and talked with you about how much
you guys want to have sex and how you'll
get along well because you have rape
fantasies you show up at his house
and then you proceed to have sex with
him like these seem to be indicators
that perhaps you are not
like that that this does not fall clear
let's just put it it does not fall
clearly into the evidenced rape category
by the way she doesn't even allege rape
just going to say that right off the bat
she arrived at portnoy's four bedroom
house about 3 p.m tired enough from her
travel she didn't mind when portnoy told
her they would order in pizza instead of
going out
still she was surprised to find him
nothing like his charismatic online
persona he was very rude he wasn't funny
at all he just reminded me of a boring
grumpy old man madison said after dinner
they started kissing
um
i have a ques
madison said so first of all when you
meet like somebody who's like boring and
old and grumpy do you normally just
start making out with them is that like
a thing that you do typically
call me naive
i don't know madison said she first
became uncomfortable when portland i
pulled out his phone and started filming
her without asking permission as she
performed oral sex on him i never said
anything i was scared he was just so
mean she said
while having oral sex with him by the
way he says as we'll see
that he never filmed her without her
permission
okay and um
and then she texted a friend two days
after having sex with portnoy saying it
was rough i felt like i was being raped
he videotaped me and spit in my mouth
and choked me so hard i couldn't breathe
she said i felt like i was just a human
sex doll
she recalls crying and shouting too much
too much and it hurts
she said portnoy just went harder okay
so portnoy just denies all of this he
says this is not true
and again i'm not sure
how you're supposed to develop a chain
of evidence based on her allegations two
days later
after having done all of these things
like just from an evidentiary level i
don't know
why
he said she said is supposed to come
down in her favor particularly
when he has now shown texts
about these people basically saying they
want to have sex with him right so for
example
portnoy was accused by two women alice
in 19 and 20 year old madison both of
whom were given aliases of aggressive
and unpleasant sexual behavior filming
them without permission and leaving them
feeling humiliated and traumatized in
the explosive november 4th article
portnoy gave a livestream yesterday
and then he showed a message from
allison
in which she texted him quote really
want to see you would do anything she
added can we bang
[Music]
okay
then
portnoy also
attacked the journalist he said that the
journalist is uh is
you know out to get him which is
obviously true
before i say this is total bs cancel
culture 101.
he showed a series of screenshots from
both of them
he pointed out how in the article
allison's sister olivia 22 says she
wanted to secure a sought-after invite
to portnoy's 2 million nantucket
mansions according to the daily mail
olivia had been messaging him to no
avail she asked alison three years
younger to try
literally in the article they are trying
they say they're trying to bait me porn
i said this isn't journalism it's
editorial saying we don't like dave
allison messaged him saying really want
to see you would do anything adding can
we bang
[Music]
after they had sex allison messaged
portnoy again saying she wanted to see
him
portnoy noted that in his reply he said
if you don't want to do anything we
won't
okay like
after he had left nantucket allison
messaged him a few days later urging him
to return i'm in shock you're still
yelling me she said like what's up dave
portnoy and then she messaged him again
sending him her phone number
it like i'm sorry it's turning to the
second accuser porno showed another
series of comments left below a tick
tock video she made she replied to a
comment saying quote the article never
said that sex was not consensual
portnoy said that he and madison after
they had sex realized we disagreed on
basically everything like oil and water
and like oil and vinegar
but he insisted their intimate relations
were entirely consensual if there was a
hidden camera in that room that would be
absolutely nothing there there there
would be absolutely nothing there he
said
the reporter then got a full staff
position okay so here was portnoy
yesterday fighting back against this
they accused me of rape period they say
they didn't there's no actual
allegations but if you read it it's like
girls running away dave won't stop
that's rape i've said this from the top
i have never done anything inappropriate
with any girl in life and i have every
girl i've basically been with who was
like this is up and if we need you to go
to bat like we will
okay so
again like the fact that portland is
fighting back against this is good now
normally the way this works in the media
is if anyone makes an allegation like
this
people start running for the hills they
start immediately apologizing saying
that they must have been misunderstood
portnoy understands that the minute you
say that you're done he gets it and
that's good again i'm not defending any
of his actual behavior here because
again i am a traditional moralist so i
don't like any of the actual behavior
here but what i do like is that he is
fighting back against a media
establishment that will go after people
based on politics
i guarantee you that every single actor
in hollywood who is major has done
things that are exactly like this
exactly like this
and then the and then
if they're ever called on it the media
basically ignore it if they happen to be
political enough
and by the way if an actor ever speaks
out about it and says i don't do this
because i'm afraid that stuff like this
will happen they rip him up remember
that henry cavill did this the guy who
play superman henry cavill said that it
was tough to date he said it was tough
to date because he didn't know
that he didn't know whether he'd be
accused of something he didn't do
he said that back in 2018 he was ripped
up and down for saying this
in a lengthy interview with gq australia
back in 2018 he said there's something
wonderful about a man chasing women
there's a traditional approach to that
which is nice i think a woman should be
wood and chase maybe i'm old-fashioned
for thinking that
he said that it's difficult to pursue a
woman that way if there are certain
rules in place he said i don't want to
go up to her because i'm going to be
called a rapist or something so you're
like forget it i'll call an
ex-girlfriend instead and go back to a
relationship which has never worked but
it's way safer than casting myself into
the fires of hell because i'm someone in
the public eye and if i go on flirt with
someone who knows what's going to happen
and he was ripped up and down
he's ripped up and down and left was
like well if he doesn't want to be
accused of rape he shouldn't rape anyone
except that you guys accuse people of
rape all the time without any sort of
evidence apparently
it doesn't require evidence
so good good on portnoy for fighting
back against this truly
and i got to say those text messages do
not cut in favor of the business insider
case that portnoy is some sort of
wild
rapey
guy who's just forcing himself on women
without their consent that's not what
those text messages show in any way
shape or form alrighty we have reached
the end of today's show however we will
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show drew
shows every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you also go check
out drew's new book head on over to
dailywire.com 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin